i'm staying at one of the most expensive
hotels in las vegas eleven thousand
dollars per night wait till you guys hit
the inside though they got hot tubs in
every room amazing food and a pool table
in the suite come on man first off the
suite has a doorbell to it so you
already know we live in fancy
first thing you see when you walk in is
the full bar so right behind it is a
mini fridge and it's filled with
everything you need we got limes for
your drinks fancy ice cubes and it's a
butler available 24 hours a day to make
you drinks give you a ride anything you
need they got you so right next to the
bar is the dining table and the first of
two living rooms
yeah yeah that's nice that's nice
the tv in here is 75 inches just wait
until i show you guys the theater room
the fridge is packed we got some fancy
wine and literally every other drink
known to mankind is in here the
cupboards are filled with mad snacks i
ate all those reese's pieces i had to
take them so now it's time for me to
show you guys why they call us the 180
suite it starts here and it gives you a
100 degree view from the strip all the
way over to the red rock mountains the
main balcony has a cool seating area
right by the hot tub it feels so good to
be sitting out here watching the sunset
it's so beautiful
we got another bar dining table out here
as well just in case you want to eat out
in the sun or something like that and
finally this super chill area in the
back is definitely a spot for only
maxing and relaxing i'm gonna take you
guys right back inside from the balcony
this is the lounge area and then we got
this telescope over here where you can
pretty much look out and see over to the
vegas trip these things are powerful
so this is one of my favorite parts of
the suite it's the pool table
and hidden behind this wall are all the
pool sticks
that's kind of fire
and just like that we're on to another
room the theater room slash the second
living room could literally fit a
football team in there the tv is 90
inches
before i got too comfortable our butlers
came to escort us to lunch because when
you live like a king you gotta eat like
a king the seafood tower was a
showstopper it had main lobster
oyster
king crab
shrimp
and scallops all flamed and drizzled
with garlic butter sauce
come on man
chef's kiss
hamachi shots with avocado
oh my god a 42 ounce tomahawk steak with
lobster tails and vegetables
some baked mac and cheese sour cream
cake with ice cream and toffee sauce
drizzle all over the top of it at this
point i'm full and before i pass out let
me show you guys these rooms this is the
guest bedroom and it comes with his own
hot tub whoa
they got a tv in the bathroom mirror
obviously
every room in this suite has a bidet
it's got one of those cool shower heads
that like rings on top of you
and it's super high up also water comes
out of every part of this shower so
beware crazy stuff crazy stuff and right
down the hall is where the magic happens
yeah i always wanted to say that
this is the main bedroom and it comes
with its own hot tub too
outside the room is a balcony that looks
over the hotel pool area
and it gives you the most amazing view
of the red rock mountains
[Music]
and lastly the best part of the suite in
my personal opinion is this shower the
coolest piece is that it's also a steam
room it takes about 10 minutes to get
going so i'm going to show you one more
cool thing before i come back so this
entire suite can be controlled by this
device you can close the shades you can
turn to lights control tvs and more for
individual rooms or everything at one
time all right now back to the shower
can you imagine how good a shower feels
when it's steamy like this
just think about all the songs you can
sing in here
[Music]
you